it's meet Friday the trigger grills are
all fired up drew brees walked in and
realized what we were cooking but I
don't know if it's gonna be done by the
time you're done here drew we can save
you some though probably proud owner of
a Trager girl himself will get to droop
coming up here in a moment
our poll question McLovin brought to you
by man vs. food okay our one who's gonna
win 57 set percent set Patriots this new
poll whose career would you want Larry
Fitzgerald Eli Manning JJ Watt Drew
Brees or Al Michaels oh wow today's
guest list and Drew Brees is second he's
the highest player but Al Michaels beats
him out I would have voted for Al
Michaels too like he's gonna he's done
it you're not gonna be playing
quarterback when you're 75 I think just
the miracle moment alone right just that
call just that call alone I think he's
had so many calls of course all those
super most of the other guys were not
alive when that guy except for me maybe
I'm 1979 so I think I I might be the
only living you're a year old that was
one year old for miracle and ice JJ Watt
deshaun Watson stop by first hour Larry
Fitzgerald in a little bit Eli Manning
and then Al Michaels will join us coming
up in the final hour of the show we say
good morning to our radio and TV
partners around the country DirecTV the
audience network they've done a great
job in setting up our mancave and yes
that is the stadium over our shoulders
drew would you validate this people
think we sort of superimpose the stadium
over our show it look like a UFO just
kind of touchdown and stay here for a
little bit and then head out
no that's the stadium that's the scene
of the crime though right right it's
tough yeah unfortunately you know people
remind you when you got into town yeah
how do they remind you well a couple of
them said come come play for the Vikings
I say never know I actually every time I
look at it I unfortunately think of that
moment but listen it was we have so much
to be proud of from our season and and
in that game in particular just what we
were able to overcome to to get that to
that point I saw Biggs yesterday
actually and he just kind of gave me
that smile and I shaved my head
yeah that was crazy more but you lead
the Saints down you get the field goal
you got the lead not much time left
yeah so what are you thinking what when
you kick a field goal with 25 seconds
left you know you you you assume that
you've got a really really really good
chance to win the game especially all
that we had overcome and they just felt
like all the momentum had shifted back
to us and listen they they never quit
and and made that play at the end that I
think will go down in history is
probably one of the greatest plays in
playoff history how do you get over it
or do you want to get over it yeah you
do I mean listen we were all we're all
shell-shocked there for a while and you
know you kind of go back and I mean
bottom line is how do you prevent that
from happening we'll kick a field goal
with no time left no don't don't give
anybody any kind of a chance to to make
a you know a miracle play like that but
III I love our team and I feel like we
overcame so much throughout the course
of the year you know to start off oh and
to you know we started the season here
Monday Night Football we lose that one
then we go to lose the Patriots were
owing to you know everybody's wanting to
say that you know we're done for and
then we went eight in a row win the NFC
South division which is an incredibly
tough division you only sent three teams
to playoffs this year B Carolina at home
and then come play against Minnesota
overcoming a 17 point deficit at
halftime I mean all those all those
things that we overcame throughout the
season watch our team grow watch us
establish an identity that I think can
carry on for years to come you know I
think we're poised to really make a run
at it
obviously you retool every offseason
every team does but I love our mindset
right now if we can stay stay home we'll
stay hungry and create that sense of
urgency throughout this offseason and
understand that you don't just start off
where you ended up you know you've got a
you've got to recreate that you've got
to work for it and I feel like we have
the right type of guys and the right
mentality to do that what's a reasonable
expectancy of your career now like give
me a window of how long you really think
that you can play well how long I can
play and how long I will play are
probably two different how long do you
want to play you know what I'm just
taking it one year at a time
honestly I I don't want to I had three
years ago had you asked me I would have
said 45 I did say 45 three years you
know you know
and that's just because I felt like I
had I had found a little bit of a fount
of youth with some of the things I was
doing from a training perspective and
diet and do I still feel like that's
possible yeah might it happen it might
but I've narrowed my mindset to be so
singular singularly focused on what's
right in front of me and just staying in
the moment as much as I can I mean I I
had more fun playing football this year
than I've had in a long long time and I
think it's because I had that that
mindset you know each and every day and
a lot of it had to do with the guys that
I had the chance to go to work with
every day the guys in the locker room
and so that gets me excited I mean that
makes me want to play as long as I
possibly can but at the end of the day
it's gonna be about my family and my
kids and the time I get to spend with
them and you know what my goals are and
what I feel like I still want to
accomplish you know in this league
bottom line right now is I want to win a
championship
who plays longer you were breeding I
don't know I mean I think he's he he
appears to have made it known that he'd
like to play a long long time it's
pretty good to be the MVP at 40 I'll
listen he's he's a stud what do you do
better than Brady well I'll keep that to
myself but how many things okay how many
things do you think you do better than
Brady what you know what to tell me what
they are I'm not gonna go there I'll I
know this I always I always have the
mindset that I've got guys that I I i
watch a lot of and he's certainly one of
them
but what are you looking for well um
there's things I can pick up from just
watching him play just understanding
that position and knowing how how you
should play it how you handle certain
situations I think mostly what I respect
about Tom is what he does to prepare
himself to play I mean you you see the
finished product every Sunday right but
you don't see everything that goes into
that there is so much that goes into
that and it's not just during the season
it's what you do during the offseason
and I know a lot of that guys routine in
regards to his his focus and his
preparation the amount of time and
effort energy
he puts into it and it's that's what
makes him a great player you know and a
lot of guys aren't willing to commit
that but I think that's what these
players these athletes lose is the
willingness to want to get better and
prepare and do put all the extra work
that goes into it as opposed to just
showing up on Sunday and then playing
you're exactly right and you have to
have that enthusiasm as well and
speaking of which segue drew is at the
Pro Bowl and as the father of four
children that's but not you know three
boys like you have those little guys on
the sidelines were more entertaining
than the Pro Bowl so you're there
playing but you're also there parenting
that's nobody else is doing that you
deserved MVP by the way now what did mom
say when she saw the boys on the
sidelines roughing each other up and he
of course the standard line from a
parent is keep your hands off of him
yeah how did that go we've had a few
conversations about this actually over
the last week because while while we can
all laugh and chuckle and it's all well
and good and boys will be boys and you
know there's there's there's some
disciplinary aspects that are lacking
[Laughter]
this up to hey we're at the Pro Bowl and
those boys were so excited you know they
were ball boys all week they got to hang
out with all the players in the locker
room on the practice field and so they
probably just got a little too
comfortable you know they get down on
the sideline I told Brittany so they
were at the game you know it's pouring
down rain I told her okay well I'm
playing I need to focus but then the
minute I'm out I'll kind of signal to
you bring the boys down and I'll let
them be on the sidelines cuz at the end
of the day I what I want to do is create
as many experiences as I can for them as
many of those moments where not only is
that time I can spend with them but you
know maybe there's some life lessons
that can be drawn from it like don't
fight on the side and wander onto the
field
you know but I was glad that we were
able to give America a good chuckle you
know and in an enjoyable moment and
maybe some physical activity you know
but now that was that was one of those
like okay boys will be boys we're all
well and good oh you're on the field
that's a problem get over here
we're gonna have a stern talking-to
you're gonna go sit with your mom if you
don't cut this out but yeah I didn't
know how mom would react because then
people want to know Oh what kind of
parents are you that you let I mean
they're down there you're trying to do
an interview with this assaulters and
they're you know all over each other and
then one gets knocked onto the playing
field yeah I'll tell you what it is is
it when there's when there's just two of
them I think there's a little more of a
level of discipline or of you know I can
I can kind of separate but but then you
got three you know I'm saying like you
only only got two arms right so it's
gonna be just on one and it's always the
two younger ones you know here's here's
Baylin he was excited about this
interview and then Callen Callens a bit
of an instigator he's the younger and
then there's middle son Bowen he's kind
of you know put your dukes up and then
banelings like what are you guys doing
Callen dummy BAM I thought I told you
not to get on the field you know so it's
a listen it's the greatest thing in the
world I mean there's challenges that
come along with it it's the high the
highest level of emotion and then you
can be as angry as you ever thought you
could possibly be like I just told you
not to touch that and you just touched
it but I think he launched himself
though huh I think your oldest launched
himself that would be fine you could you
could do that to your kids you should
throw flags and just say alright that's
15 minutes in timeout over there I
believe in I do I mean I do call being a
dad a referee in a lot of cases you know
you're just you're roughing the mayhem
you know it's like I said boys will be
boys like they're still making all these
connections in their brain like you you
know and and all the roughhouse stuff is
good I mean because they that's how they
that's how they find their limits right
as to what they're capable of how far to
push it when it's okay I've gone too far
I've hurt somebody or I've hurt myself I
mean there's some things that are just
necessary about that and yet I just try
to keep it fair you know I'm saying yeah
like I'll let him go at it on me [ __ ] it
all day long but it's like stay off the
head/neck no eye gouging no pulling hair
I ready fight we're good my kind of dad
drew is joining us on behalf of
Microsoft Surface if you'd like to
explain what you're doing with Microsoft
Microsoft has been a great partner of
mine our foundation in the NFL I'm
always advancing technology NFL making
things more efficient it's been a great
sideline tool for us with the surface as
well and the cool thing is we've been
able to experiment with actually doing
live video on the sidelines on the
surface as opposed to just still shots
during the season and still shots Pro
Bowl we did live video which would be
such a game changer if the NFL would
would Institute that why into well
because there's there's things you miss
when you're just doing still shots you
know me there's there's four shots from
each play that you get to look at when
you come to the sideline so it's pre
snap and then it's like every second or
two after well inevitably there's things
in that second or two that you would
miss whereas if you're watching video
you can see it I remember a couple two
Pro Bowls ago when I was with a Antonio
Brown and and there was a play on in the
red zone where he went but he went
behind a guy and I would have wanted him
to go in front I would have missed that
in the picture whereas in the video I
could actually see that moment we we
talked about it we come out the next
drive we run the same play he comes
underneath we catch it touchdown so the
those type of examples where okay that
it actually applied there and it helped
us so it's a Microsoft Surface any other
info you want to give out on this you're
good I'm good hey it's always great by
the way all the great quarterbacks who
have stopped by Marino Rogers Alex Smith
they've thrown a couple passes to
McLovin yeah usually he's he's trash
he's a trash talker he's been making fun
of Alex Smith's arm strength okay
Rogers did you say something to Rogers
Moreno
oh yeah war buggy no I have nothing Eli
Manning you said you wanted to actually
get a pass from a real good quarterback
named Manning nothing to say I mean no
anything means gonna say what what's
what do you have for me
well nothing I'm just i logistical II
it's a good set up because I could go
down those stairs over there be Jews not
as tall as the other quarterbacks
probably can generate as much Wow during
the commercial break if you'd like to
watch McLovin take his life in his own
hands we used to give quarterbacks three
throws and you decide what kind of
velocity you would like three throws yes
boy and and the backdrop of the stadium
drew may really let out his aggression
uh-huh yes oh that's great
now remind him that he lost I just try
to get McLovin hurt yeah in dramatic
fashion to the Minnesota Vikings all
right we'll come back well you can do
three if he wanted to but you know to
know you may not need the warm-ups or
nothing how are you gee whiz are you
gonna lick your fingers after the throw
before the throw a Milo enough I don't
want you to know he's being serious here
yes a Milo enough for Drew I appreciate
you dropping it down yeah all right
all right this this first one's gonna be
real real soft okay catch just to kind
of get like that just to kind of get
loose you know it's just kind of they
complete 72 percent of his passes
yeah all right am i aiming whoever you
there's a bull's-eye on his helmet I see
that I like that well done well done
well done
Wow
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay well done Norman please that's
funny thank you ma'am thank you spirals
so no um I gave him the wig yeah
all right I'm coming over Trager yes
you're impossible thank you
brisket ribs oh yeah what'll beat ya BJ
love it good scores here for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]